[Music]
this
celebratory rally in havana is a far cry
from angry protests that have gripped
this caribbean nation
performing cuban salsa and waving flags
thousands of people showed support
for president miguel diaz-canel he says
protests against cuba's economic decline
were based on false narratives they are
encouraging and glorifying disrespect
and destruction of property
threats and harassments of citizens and
families
right now what the world is seeing from
cuba is a lie
raul castro joined the president who he
had handed power to
in 2019. he and his brother the late
fidel castro
had led the cuban revolution more than
six decades ago
pandemic or no pandemic we have to
defend this revolution
we have to defend what is ours
in the words of miguel diaz-canel he
made it clear to the whole world
that this revolution will not be
overthrown
a week ago a wave of protests hit 40
cuban cities
the biggest in decades
people are calling for liberty freedom
and down with the dictatorship
they galvanized in their thousands over
shortages of goods
and the government's handling of a surge
in covert 19 infections
scores of people were arrested
[Applause]
almost 2 000 kilometers north in
washington dc
protesters showed solidarity outside the
cuban embassy
my grandmother left in 1970 without the
expectation of going back
and because of the dictatorship in cuba
we have not been afforded that
opportunity
those calls were echoed among the large
cuban american population in florida
u.s president joe biden called cuba a
failed state
and showed no sign of lifting economic
sanctions
the country now seems divided between
two camps
those who blame the government on
widespread shortages of food
and medicine and those who don't want to
lose their socialist revolution
they blame 60 years of crippling
sanctions for their economic woes
al jazeera